What’s happening to your tax money?
President Trump said,
"I'm going to cut some departments."
We’re proposing a budget
that will shrink the bloated federal bureaucracy.
But that didn't happen.
Quietly, Congress increased spending
on the very departments Trump wanted to cut.
Important sounding agencies like
the Agriculture Department.
Which raises the question.
What does the Agriculture Department do?
Um I'm sure they do a bunch of things.
No one I asked knew.
What does agriculture do?
FDA?
No.
3/4ths of the money goes for programs
like food stamps
And lots of that is wasted.
Billions went to dead people.
And billions more go for corporate welfare,
farm subsidies.
Years ago, politicians said,
government must help farmers
to make sure America has an ample food supply.
The whole thing is a big boondoggle which
gives some farmers subsidies,
but the vast majority of farmers don’t get subsidized
and it still gets grown.
Yes, somehow, we always have enough vegetables
and fruit,
crops that don’t get subsidies.
The subsidies mostly go to grain and corn farmers.
The richest farmers get most of the handouts.
What they’re really doing is taking from
the private sector
and they’re giving it to special interests.
And yet at the same time, the government demands
other farmers grow less.
To prop up cherry prices, the department told this farmer,
“destroy your crop!”
He had to dump
40,000 lbs
of perfectly good cherries
on the ground and let them rot.
The result is we have fewer cherries
and we have to pay more for existing cherries.
That’s not helping.
Other cabinet departments are just as wasteful.
What about the Commerce Department?
What do they do?
I have no idea.
No one did.
The department’s biggest spending item is
supporting the global warming science complex.
The ice is also thinning at an alarming rate.
The Commerce Department spends your money
at an alarming rate.
They bought a $300,000 yacht
which the bureaucrats used to go fishing.
The department also gives money to
companies that have tech problems.
They claim: “every dollar generates $30.”
They take a $1
and then they get
$30 of benefits for society.
All we need to do is take more of your dollar
and we get 30 times the amount.
The unseen is, if we’re not spending that $1,
that’s being taken from the economy too.
So if we spend that $1,
why doesn’t that become $30?
It’s the biggest Ponzi scheme example
logic I’ve heard of.
And think about just this idea
of a commerce department.
When one of the founders was asked about
about creating the department, he said
"for heaven's sake,
what is meant by a government Chamber of Commerce?”
Commerce just happens.
We don’t need a Commerce Department.
$14 back, thank you sir.
Why don’t we just let people do what they
want to do
– interact freely.
Wouldn’t that be nice!
But that’s not happening,
under Democrats and Republicans, government grows.